a former prosecutor at the centre of New
York's notorious Central Park five rape
case faces very strong backlash after
the release of a hard-hitting Netflix
series Linda fair Stein stepped down
from the boards of a college and a
non-profit charity she was the top
Manhattan sex crimes prosecutor when
five teenagers were wrongfully convicted
following the 1989 attack on a female
jogger CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller has covered the Central
Park five four years and joins us with
this latest turn of events
Michelle good morning to you good
morning many are hearing about this case
for the first time because of the series
when they see us
Linda Fair sign is played by Felicity
Huffman a roll film before Hoffman
admitted to participating in the College
Admission scandal she's seen as a
single-minded prosecutor convinced of
the young men's guilt they brutally
raped a woman and discarded her like a
piece of garbage when they see us
revisits Manhattan Central Park five a
case which drew national headlines in
1989 it focuses not only on the black
and Latino teens who were accused of
attacking and raping a female investment
banker but also on the woman who helped
successfully convict them prosecutor
Linda fair Stein these kids were on a
rampage the accused later said they were
coerced into confessing these young men
were the proxies for all kinds of other
agendas sarah burns produced and
directed a 2012 documentary about the
case I think a lot of people now with
the new series are coming to this story
and learning about what happened and it
makes people upset I didn't see a lady
or hit anyone the city of New York
reached a 41 million dollar settlement
with the five in two thousand fourteen
years after another man confessed linked
to the crime by DNA evidence since the
Netflix series debut last Friday the
backlash against fare Stein now an
author has exploded the hashtag cancel
Linda fair Stein trended on Twitter and
more than 75,000 people signed an online
petition calling for a
boycott of her children's books and
mystery novels Raymond Santana left jail
a free man
we interviewed Raymond Santana one of
the Central Park five after his
exoneration what do you say to the
people out there who just don't believe
you're innocent these people had in mind
fixated on I was being guilty we have
tried everything we possibly could
Santana now tells TMZ that fair stein
deserves the scrutiny she is now getting
and even though it's 30 years later she
has to pay for her crime in the wake of
the miniseries release fair stein has
resigned from Vassar Colleges Board of
Trustees as well as the board of the
victims Service Agency safe horizon in a
letter to the agency's chairman
she says the show depicts me in a
fictionalized version of events in a
grossly and maliciously inaccurate
manner I think in part why this is
directed more at Linda fair scene is
that she has remained steadfast in her
belief in the guilt of the Central Park
five in a statement to CBS this morning
fair Stein's lawyer said the series
director Ava Duvernay
ignored the vast majority of readily
publicly available material about the
case all in the name of fabricated
sensationalism Duvernay declined our
request for comments well Ava Duvernay
was here at the table before the the
series came out and and it was very
clear about all the research she had
done all the interviews that she
personally conducted herself and when
you talk to the Central Park five and
you hear their story their story and I
asked them individually does his film
represent what happened to you all and
they said it's eerie how Wow dead on and
how right they said Ava got this
painting if you're wondering what fair
Stein thinks about the case she talked
to The New Yorker back in 2002 about the
investigation and she said things like a
kid would say something like a
dark-skinned guy who lives on a hundred
and second Street and these detectives
would go out and find him I think it was
one of the most brilliant police
investigations I've ever seen which by
the way is exactly how it's depicted in
that Netflix documentary they were
exonerated you look for an apology at
the very least or own your decision in
which
nothing to apologize for that's the one
that's a point but this it's a really a
lesson it is a lesson about the power of
justice in the hands of those who have
it the police the prosecutors the public
defenders and the judges she called it
brilliant twice in that interview we'll
have much more on this I think not not
the end Michelle thank you very much and
we'd like to talk to Linda Farah Stein -
yeah indeed we've invited her